you know the last time i saw you i think
it was at the premiere of your movie
there was a documentary on david that
was fantastic and i i suggest you watch
it
yeah it was really good and i was there
and i was sitting behind you
and i you know as i was watching the
documentary it kind of made me feel like
you were going to die at any minute
because they were talking about all your
various health problems
i remember at one point i leaned forward
to i wasn't sure if you were breathing
or not i wanted to check on you because
i got so goddamn nervous during it
i was like i think he just died during
the movie premiere but
you were fine you were good but you know
the movie gives you that sense but then
also the movie gives you
i was afraid you were losing your home
you had no money and you know i was
afraid too but
well here's what happened no money from
streaming
so no money from records so then i was
trying to be grateful that i could still
go out and work and
you know pay the rent and take care of
my family and along comes covet and i
can't go out and work
so what i did was i sold my publishing
to uh our pal
irving the little big irving azov irving
azol yeah
he's been my friend for a long time he
gave me a ton of money
i paid off the house you should have
seen my wife's
smile when i told her i paid off the
house
but wait a second david like watching
the scene come up
even being the worst of the worst
junkies or whatever
you want to put it you always had the
wherewithal to hold on to your
publishing
from all your you know all kind of a
shocker i don't know how that happened
but there it is
you know but what about psychologically
when you sell off these songs
i understand you needed the money and
made total sense but emotionally what
did you go through was it
was it one of them you don't no no you
why
and as usual you you figured it uh it's
emotionally it sucks it's not not good
at all uh
but it solved my problem and uh
it made me able to take care of my
family and they really matter to me man
i'm not worried about it i'm not worried
about it i don't think they're going to
do anything cheesy with it i think
they're going to try to increase the
take
i'm i'm trying to uh have another career
i think maybe based on that ask cross
and rolling stone thing i really like it
that's right
i love it david's got this thing he does
for rolling stone i watch it all the
time you can
i see it on twitter and everything and
and people actually write in
to david crosby for advice and he even
says i have no idea why you're asking me
for advice but
the advice seems the advice seems very
solid to me i mean you seem
wise like this wise age you know and and
you even say look i [ __ ] up a lot of
my life so
but i'll i'll give you any advice you
need and and and there's a lot of stuff
in there
it's a curmudgeons dream man you know
it's
really fun